pour
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouveau numéro du sky échos votre
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes au siège d'antemeta à
guyancourt
cette pme est spécialisée dans les
services du numérique et elle est
actuellement en train de construire son
futur
soc un centre d'opération de cyber
sécurité et la cybersécurité il en sera
question dans cette émission mais
justement voici le sommaire du troisième
numéro du sky ego le succès de
l'alternance auprès des jeunes ils sont
de plus en plus à choisir ce parcours
face à la crise le gouvernement propose
des aides aux entreprises pour embaucher
des alternants immersion au sein de
l'entreprise
antemeta et rencontre avec son président
stéphane blanche une société en plein
développement dans ses différentes
activités
enfin la commissaire européenne maria
gabriel s'est rendu à la paris games
week
durant cet événement sur la
cybersécurité elle a expliqué la
stratégie de l'union européenne et des
territoires
dans ce domaine
[Musique]
je
antemeta accompagne les entreprises dans
leurs services numériques que ce soit le
stockage ou encore la cyber sécurité
cette entreprise emploie 180
collaborateurs sur son siège à
guyancourt avec 90 millions de chiffre
d'affaires réalisés en 2019
c'est une entreprise en plein
développement et en plus elle agrandit
son bâtiment et nous sommes avec son
président et co fondateur stéphane blanc
bonjour
sinon jean nicolas vous avez bien très
bien merci et vous écoutez pas mal
[Musique]
antemeta se porte plutôt bien 460 mètres
carrés de plus en cours de construction
en ce moment exactement on reconstruit
effectivement une surface importante
pour accueillir nos activités de soc et
de nok tout on va dire l'activité
nécessitant un grand niveau de sécurité
est donc dans lequel on souhaite
également que nos collaborateurs soit
plus tôt qu'aucun et voilà c'est un peu
c'est un peu l'objectif parce que la
sécurité veut pas dire que on n'est pas
un bon espace de travail juste un point
soc noc
ouais qu'est ce que ça signifie alors le
soc a pour objectif de surveiller en
permanence l'intégralité du système
d'information de nos clients
d'accord qui sont connectés à travers
notre cloud de cloud privé de cloud
hybride ou de cloud public qui sont
connectés à travers le haut et puis le
nok et bien c'est la sécurité
alors non pas effectivement d'accès mais
c'est la sécurité en lui-même des
données ddd data c'est on va dire la
couche la couche inférieure du système
de production voilà il ya la couche
autres le soc et le knock la couche
basse le socle à c'est ce qui se passe
ici nous sommes dans un sac voilà on a
volontairement on vous montre pas tout
parce que effectivement c'est sécurisé
c'est quand même très sécurisé donc les
tableaux qui ont été choisis mais par
contre on est en temps réel ce que vous
voyez en sa fiche est effectivement en
temps réel ici sont le type de deux on
va dire d'un point de vue technique de
reniflard qui effectué par des tiers sur
les équipements dédiés à nos clients
voilà comme vous pouvez voir il ya
beaucoup d'activités reniflage c'est
repérer les les années folles les
failles
je repère des failles je vois en fait
c'est exactement comme une maison
considéré qu' il ya quelqu'un qui ouvre
essayé d'ouvrir les portes les fenêtres
de l'entente de l'intégralité de votre
maison pour voir s'il n'y a pas une
porte ou une fenêtre qui est ouverte
d'accord ces salles à partir des flashs
d'abord une partie de découverte s'en
suit derrière
en fonction de la situation on va voir
si on va passer par la fenêtre par la
cheminée
par des égouts voilà tout et tout est
possible et c'est exactement comparer ça
à votre votre maison alors je le disais
vous agrandissez vos locaux mais c'est
accompagné aussi d'une grande vague de
recrutement chez vous alors il ya en
fait cet emplacement bâtiment sert à a
regroupé à la fois donc comme je vous le
disais le socle noc mais c'est aussi
parce que effectivement on est en train
de converger deux activités qui pour
nous sont stratégiques
l'activité de data management
anciennement activités back up d'accord
et l'activité soc notre sécurité mais
pour répondre à votre question donc
effectivement hors groupe du coup comme
regroupe ces deux activités on est en
train d'embaucher à peu près dix
personnes aujourd'hui qui regroupe à la
fois de la cyber mais aussi du data
management parce que c'est ça c'est
cette convergence qui a du sens
aujourd'hui au vu du niveau d' attaque
qu'on se prend en europe mais également
à l'étranger
un dernier mot stéphane blanc on l'a vu
une période compliquée c'était un étang
c'était la crise sanitaire compliqué
pour les entreprises qui ont dû se
réorganiser travailler en réseau avec le
télétravail est ce que vous avez eu un
impact sur votre activité
parce que qui dit réseau et travaillent
en réseau dit sécurité de ses réseaux
alors deux activités les chantiers matin
une activité négoce d'accord qui elle a
subi plus tôt une décroissance parce que
les projets ont été plus ou moins j'ai
par contre activités cloud services
managés ses sorties bien évidemment un
petit peu renforcé parce que
effectivement nos clients qui étaient
déjà dans notre cloud ou dans nos
services managés ou d'autres qui étaient
déjà client sonné une nécessité à venir
consommer en urgence des usages liés
effectivement au surplus de consommation
qu'impliquait les usages des de leurs
collaborateurs qui étaient en modèle
externaliser tout à fait voilà
effectivement là il ya eu un surplus de
sécurité et on n'a pas vu encore je suis
désolé d'être un peu de prédire un petit
peu l'avenir mais je pense que forcément
ça crée des failles de sécurité
bien évidemment pas forcément j'espère
chez nous mais je pense que ça crée des
failles de sécurité
voilà merci stéphane blanc je vous en
prie président et co-fondateur
d'antemeta
[Musique]
à
c'était la deuxième édition de la paris
games week le mercredi 30 septembre et
le jeudi 1er octobre à la maison de la
chimie à paris un événement auquel
participent et saint quentin en yvelines
au programme des échanges des rencontres
entre les acteurs de la cyber sécurité
et parmi les invités maria gabriel
commissaire européenne à l'innovation et
à la recherche
avec elle nous avons fait le point sur
la filière cybersécurité et sur le
travail de l'union européenne avec les
territoires regarder
[Musique]
d'abord la cyber sécurité il est
vraiment au fondement de ce qu'on
voudrait réussir comme une europe adapté
à la transformation numérique
[Musique]
cela concerne nos données personnelles
cela concerne la sécurité de nos
services de nos produits
cela concerne tout simplement la
sécurité de notre économie et de notre
société
nous avons besoin d'experts aujourd'hui
il manque 300 mille experts en
cybersécurité
[Musique]
comment attirer la jeunesse je crois que
si on trouve des méthodes adaptées pour
chaque âge parce que ce n'est pas la
même la même chose aux primaires que
dans l'université
le démontrer tout simplement
l'extraordinaire diversité des métiers
de cyber on a plus de chances d'avoir
des jeunes nous avons besoin de nos
enseignantes et enseignants qui puisse
parler les métiers de la cybersécurité
qu'ils puissent avoir accès à des
formations en ce moment nous avons
quarante et une alliance européenne les
universités c'est notre grande
initiative pour l'espace européen de
l'éducation qui doit être réalisé d'ici
[Musique]
collectivités territoriales longtemps
rôle fondamental à jouer je ne me
réjouis que dans le domaine de la
recherche de l'innovation de l'éducation
de la culture pour la première fois nous
avons décidé ensemble avec le comité des
régions de faire un plan d'action
conjoint pour les deux prochaines années
pour nous le rôle des régions sur la
fondamentale et pour la transformation
numérique et pour la nécessité d'avoir
plus de personnes qui ont les
compétences numériques de base et
avancées nécessaires pour créer des
entreprises pour créer des start up pour
permettre à nos services administratifs
électronique d'être au plus haut point
apprendre un métier dans une structure
spécialisée et en entreprise le principe
de l'alternance un mode de plus en plus
plébiscité puisque le nombre d'apprentis
a augmenté de 16% entre 2018 et 2019 et
dans le contexte de crise sanitaire et
économique des aides sont proposées aux
entreprises pour embaucher des
alternants les conseils et les
explications dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
d
l'alternance c'est la voie choisie par
manas rabat si cette jeune étudiante de
20 ans est actuellement en master
management des affaires et elle est en
contrat d'apprentissage chez y aspire
cette start-up incubés au ski cub a
développé une application pour mettre en
relation les sportifs partons à la
rencontre de man arabe assis dans ma vie
de salarié
[Musique]
je suis mal à rabat si j'ai 20 ans je
prépare un master en management
d'affaires en alternant shaiya spees
j'occupe le poste de responsable
partenariats et aspi c'est une société
qui commercialise une application donc
qui permet de mettre en relation des
professionnels du sport avec des
particuliers mam et son principal sava
d'entretenir les relations avec les
partenariats spees quotidiennement ça va
être des appels des prises de rendez
vous avec des personnes des coachs ou
des associations des salles de sport qui
peuvent être intéressés par notre
concept
[Musique]
je me suis plusieurs fois retrouvé dans
des situations où cette application
aurait pu m'aider
ce qui est bien en fait d'intégrer une
start up plutôt qu'un grand groupe sais
que je peux faire preuve de créativité
et d'initiative au quotidien c'est vrai
que l'instabilité du startup pourrait
plus m'inquiéter
mais la mission qu'on m'a confié me
challenge et me donne personnellement
envie d'aider à développer cette ce
projet le fait que le projet son appel
lancé moi ça me donne envie de me
construire avec et de le voir grandir en
fait tous les jours
[Musique]
l'avantagé principal du fait d'être en
alternance est de pouvoir mettre en
pratique mes connaissances dans des
tâches quotidiennes concrètes
mon rythme c'est d'une semaine par mois
à l'école et trois semaines par mois en
entreprise
donc je peux être pleinement investi
dans mon post
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 à bientôt
pour un nouveau numéro du sky échos
[Musique]
m